se reunieron en el centro de gerzón para
denunciar la ocupación rusa pero las
fuerzas de moscú respondieron con gases
lacrimógenos y disparos lo que obligó a
los manifestantes a huir gerson cayó en
la primera semana de la invasión de
rusia ucrania pero sigue siendo la única
ciudad importante capturada por moscú
hasta ahora el ejército ucraniano sigue
estableciendo una dura resistencia
estancando el avance de rusia we have
seen in the case jones hemos visto
indicios de que los ucranianos se están
yendo un poco más a la ofensiva ahora
han estado defendiendo de manera muy
inteligente muy ágil muy creativa en
lugares que creen que son los lugares
correctos para defender
algunos funcionarios occidentales
pronosticaron que la capital ucraniana
caería dentro de las 72 horas
posteriores al inicio de la invasión
pero casi un mes después que todavía
está fuera del alcance de rusia los
intentos de moscú por rodear la capital
se han visto obstaculizados por los
contraataques de lado craneano el martes
las fuerzas ucranianas expulsaron a las
tropas rusas del suburbio de macarí en
kiev lo que les permitió retomar una vía
clave al oeste de la capital
mientras tanto moscú dice que capture o
parcialmente los suburbios del noroeste
de butch a esto mail e irving en el sur
siguiente habiendo bombardeos sobre
mariupol buques de guerra rusos atacan
el puerto estratégico desde el mar de
azov las fuerzas de moscú también tienen
sus ojos puestos en el cruce al puerto
de odessa ubicado en el mar negro
pero por el momento las tropas están
estancadas en mykolaiv a unos 130 km del
puerto
funcionarios de inteligencia
estadounidenses estiman que la parte
rusa ha perdido 7.000 soldados desde el
comienzo de la invasión un gran número
en comparación a los 4 mil 900 soldados
estadounidenses que murieron durante la
guerra en irak que duró 8 años